rob are you just like why why are you
just hiding people rob
you ro why is rob comes in and
immediately just fat fingers and hides
somebody i fixed it
um jesus christ rob
you piece of rob gavigan your piece of
i'm gonna challenge rob to a boxing
match because
literally everybody else is doing it
rob gavigan we're gonna have a boxing
match
we're gonna have a boxing match
we're doing it it's happening pick a
place
pick a time and we're going to have a
[ __ ] just
straight up you know what rob
i'm going to up no no no i'm up in the
stakes here rob
i'm up in the stakes it's gonna be a
foxy boxing match
we're gonna be wearing bikinis and oiled
up
i am right now i am calling out
rob gavigan to a foxy
boxing match
all right foxy boxing
and not only that rob
not only that i'm stealing your look
it's mine now i'm wearing the hat now
so [ __ ] i'm in foxy boxing match we're
doing it
we're doing it it's happening
entrance music get ready it better be
something dope to get you hyped
because here's here's your problem all
right here's your problem
you already know you already know
that i got mine picked out rob foxy
boxing
let's do it come on rob bring it
hey rob you should have changed your
name from dyke
to [ __ ] because i'm gonna [ __ ]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
and whatever while we're boxing if we
make out a little who cares like i don't
think it's
we make out a little bit so what so we
touch butts
who cares if we touch butts rob i don't
i don't care anyway look my point is
it's not it's not it's not it's not
if it's in the oh so i'm sorry
we're [ __ ] greco-roman wrestlers who
used to wrestle in the nude
no they were [ __ ] alpha chads so i'm
sorry but you're not
the couple things you're gonna tell me
is two oiled up dudes just you know
[ __ ]
doing it
oh [ __ ] all right rob let's see rob rob
says he facebook messaged me his son
let's see
oh no
why is that
sorry why is this your entrance
i'm already laughing before i play it
all right look
this is this is rob's entrance song
oh [ __ ]
get ready you know what
here it comes here he comes
there's no music
[Laughter]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
i don't know i don't know what big of a
hype song that is
[Music]
right
it's an invitation this is
[ __ ] amazing i mean i guess it's past
8 million views i've never seen this
this
is amazing
i can see it rob you wait if you're
coming into this any man that comes into
this
is going to destroy you it's going to
destroy you
across
oh [ __ ] man dc now
don't forget
on the streets of brazil
back in the uh ussr
i guess i guess i should have known
about this but i did it and this is
amazing and now i have a [ __ ]
absolute rabbit hole that i'm gonna go